führen, wenn Sie damit einverstanden sind.
Ja, natürlich.
Sondern jemand hilft mir.
Achso, haben Sie sehr steil für Schmerzen?
Ist die zu raus?
Ja, mein Bauch tut mir so.
Wie wissen Sie, hier oben im Bauch und es wird irgendwie...
Das wird immer schlimmer, ja.
Brauchen Sie ein Schmerzuntel oder können Sie am...
Ich hab das jetzt schon eine ganze Weile.
Jetzt können wir auch noch eben zusammen reden.
Okay, dann brauche ich zuerst tatsächlich einige persönliche und allgemeine Informationen.
Wie zum Beispiel... wie heißen Sie denn?
Und herrst du Thomas Wagner?
Thomas Wagner.
Am Ende...nachname ist am Ende ER.
Hab ich richtig gespielt?
N-E-R, ja, genau. Wagner.
Okay, und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Wagner?
Ich bin genau 60.
Wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
Heute ist Ihre Geburtstag.
Am 1.7.65.
Ein...un...
Können Sie bitte noch mal sagen, wie es so ist?
Am 1.7.65.
Und herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Wie so 1.7?
Das ist im Juli.
Sorry.
Juli.
Ja, sorry.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie so seit?
Ich bin noch 74 Kilo und ich bin 1,83 groß.
Okay, Herr Wagner, haben Sie sehr starke Schmerzen?
Seit wann haben Sie tatsächlich so Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat angefangen, ja, bestimmt schon...
...vom Vierteljahr, so.
Aber jetzt wird es in der letzten Zeit,
so in den letzten 2, 3 Wochen, es ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Und also hier oben im Bauch tut das sowieso so unterhalb der Brust,
so oberhalb vom Bauchnabel, würde ich sagen, ja.
Oh, und das sind solche Schmerzen.
Das zieht und ja, in letzter Zeit ist es richtig schlecht geworden.
Okay, wann treten diese Schmerzen auf nach dem Essen
oder nach dem bestimmten Bewegungen?
Naja, ich würde sagen, sie sind ein Ich-Permanin, ja.
Ich könnte jetzt nicht sagen, dass da irgendwas...
Sind die Schmerzen immer da?
Hab ich dich falsch gemacht?
Ja, ja.
Manchmal lassen die die Schmerzen nach, oder?
Ja, wenn ich schlafe, merke ich es halt nicht so, ne.
Dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich mal so ein bisschen Ruhe hab.
Aber eigentlich ist es permanent ziemlich schlecht.
Und ja, mir ist auch so schlecht.
Und...
Nacht schwitzt sich ganz doll.
Und also, ja, ich muss auch ständig zur Toilette hin, ne.
Ich hab permanent Durchfall, also...
Ja, ganz eklig, ja.
Okay, und leiden Sie so seit unterdire,
oder Durchfall oder Verstoffung?
Nee, also Durchfall, Durchfall, also immer wieder.
Und das sieht so... Ja, das sieht ganz komisch aus.
Das ist so ganz helles Zeug, das sieht ein bisschen fies aus.
So, und haben Sie auch im Stuhlgang
oder im Stuhl Blut bemerkt oder einfach hell?
Ne, Blut ist mir da nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, und streiten die Schmerzen irgendwo in ihrem Körper aus?
Nee, also die sind eigentlich so hier oben im Bauch
und gehen so einmal runter und so um hier in den Rücken
und im oberen Bauch, würde ich sagen, so runter rum.
Okay, und haben Sie so seit Fieber oder lässt ihr seit haben,
hatten Sie Fieber?
Oh, ich hab mich nicht gemessen.
Ich hab mich nicht gemessen, aber also,
ich schwitz in der Nacht, schwitz sich tatsächlich ziemlich doll, ja.
Okay, wegen der vermehrtlichen Witzen
sehen Sie tatsächlich unter Hemd mehrmals um, oder?
Ja, also einmal in der Nacht muss ich bestimmt ausstehen
und mein Nachthemd ausziehe, also mein Schlafanzug ausziehen, ne.
Okay, und gibt es auch etwas, die die Schmerzen verschlimmern
oder verbessern?
Wie gesagt, wenn ich nach...
Ich merke, die Schmerzen halten wir nicht, ne.
Aber sonst ist es eigentlich schon so, dass die permanent da sind
und dass sie eben immer schlechter werden.
Okay, ja, verstehe.
Und...
Mir schmeckt es auch überhaupt nicht, wissen Sie.
Mir schmeckt das Essen überhaupt nicht, mir ist immer schlecht.
Und ja, ich bin auch tatsächlich ein bisschen erschrocken.
Ich hab sonst immer 82 kg gehoben,
jetzt wiege ich nur noch 74.
Ich hab mit einmal in den letzten Monaten wohl ordentlich abgenommen.
In den letzten Monaten haben Sie tatsächlich 2 kg abgenommen.
Nee, mehr.
Ich hab immer 82 gewogen,
jetzt wiege ich nur noch 74, ich hab also 8 kg abgenommen.
Ja, ja.
Okay, ich...
Und fühlen Sie sich auch schwach
oder muskulisch, welche Abgeschlagenheit
man jetzt wirklich bei...
Wenn man ständig Schmerzen hat und ständig durchfällt,
dann ist man schon ein bisschen schlapp unterwegs, ja.
Denken Sie Genugwasser?
Ja, Wasser ist eigentlich nicht so meine Stärke, ja.
Also, ja, ich trinke lieber was anderes.
Ich trinke lieber mal ein Bier oder so.
Aber in letzter Zeit haben wir das auch nicht viel geschmeckt.
Okay, aber halten Sie hier keine Bestimmte,
die jetzt habe ich nicht verstanden.
Die Eht... na ja, also ich hab dann schon mal...
versucht, dass ich jetzt nicht fettig esse
oder so, weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
dass das den Durchfall doch schlimmer macht.
Aber, ja, ich muss ja nun auch keinen Tee trinken.
Der schmeckt mir wirklich nicht.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Und war Ihnen übel oder haben Sie schon einmal...
Und mir ständig übel, ja.
Aber ich musste mich nicht...
also, ich musste nicht mich übergeben.
Das lohne ich aber.
Ich habe mir das Essen eigentlich...
Ja, das mich das auch nicht besonders lockt.
Ich habe dann mal ein Toastbrot gegessen
und mal so... auch mal überbacken oder so.
Und... und hab mir sogar auch mal eine Suppe gekocht.
Aber, ja, so doll ist das nicht mehr im Essen.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Dann verstehe ich, dass ich das nicht...
hab ich ein bisschen... Sie ein bisschen...
ähm, apetitlosigkeit habe.
Ja.
Okay.
Und ich würde gerne mich...
ein bisschen über Ihren...
Äh, Küpperfunktionen informieren.
Wieso Beispiel haben Sie auch Probleme...
ähm, beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, Probleme habe ich da eigentlich nicht.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass... das der Urin,
der sieht so ganz dunkel aus,
in letzter Zeit.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Schwierigkeiten
beim Wasserlassen oder Schmerzen?
Hm, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, neutrücken wir wohl.
Und in letzter Zeit
ist Ihnen aufgefallen
ähm, ein vermehrter Herzschlag
oder Schwierigkeiten bei der Atmung?
Nee, also ich bauch Schmerzen,
aber die Luft kann ich gut kriegen, ja.
Also ein bisschen Rauchhauchwuchsten habe ich.
Ja, also... das ist schon...
aber also nicht, dass ich jetzt
irgendwie Atemnot habe oder so.
Okay, ja.
Ja, stimmt.
Verzeihdankbar.
Und ich würde gerne auch...
ähm,
auf Ihre Vorerkrankungen
wie so Operationen reingehen.
In der Vergangenheit
hatten Sie schon einmal
ähm, eine Operation durchgefüllt
worden.
Aber es ist schon ewig lange her,
vor 25 Jahren war das.
25 Jahre?
Okay, und operativ behandelt
war das richtig?
Ja, das ist damals
gerichtet worden und fixiert worden
und noch nicht mehr.
Und dann haben Sie es
in der Vergangenheit
geholfen,
und dann haben Sie es in der Vergangenheit
in der Vergangenheit geholfen.
Und dann haben Sie es in der Vergangenheit
geholfen und fixiert worden und da mussten
hinterher die Platten natürlich immer wieder raus.
So, ein Platten-
Platten-
Eingesetzt.
Okay, und
nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Nein.
Ich war eigentlich, denke ich, immer bisher
so gesund, also...
Verzeihdankbar, super.
Und ich würde gerne auch über
Ihre
Genussmittelgewöhnlichkeiten
brauchen Sie?
Ja, weg.
Ja, ja, ja, also rauchen durch.
Früher habe ich
vielleicht ein halbeschachtel
am Tag geraucht, aber jetzt
in letzter Zeit hau ich
schon eher eine Schachtel an.
Und dann, halb wissen Sie, ich bin
ganz seit zu Hause,
ich hab mein Job verloren und
ja, und lebt von meiner Frau getrennt.
Wir sind geschieden und
ja, und da ist der Tag schon lange
und dann hilft es mal, zwischendurch eine
Zigarette zu rauchen und
abends ein Papier zu trinken, ja.
Dann seit wann
rauchen Sie mehr als früher
ein Schachtel-Sigarette?
Mhm.
Ja, also ich rauch bestimmt
jetzt schon 10 Jahre rauch ich mehr.
Okay.
Und in der Vergangenheit
oder eingesamt
haben Sie ungefähr 10 Jahre lang geraucht?
Ja, nee, also
in 10 Jahren rauch ich jetzt mehr.
Und davor
habe ich halt, was war nicht
20 Jahre, 30 Jahre
habe ich, habe ich
nicht so viel geraucht.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich so viel, aber
wenn Sie möchten, mit dem rauchen
aufhören möchten, würde ich
gerne auch für Sie ein
rauchen-at-Wöhnung
beratungsorganisieren.
Ah, wissen Sie, das muss ich erst mal
meine Bauchschmerzen los machen.
Wissen Sie, irgendwas muss der Mensch ja noch haben.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Wackner?
Ja, habe ich ja gesagt,
dass ich abends gerne mal ein paar Flaschen Bier trinke
und so, aber zurzeit schmeckt es mir
auch nicht so gut, muss ich sagen.
Aber ich mag
kein Wasser trinken
und kein Tee, das ist ja kein Getränk.
Also, nee,
also ein paar Bier müssen schon abends sein,
eigentlich.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Und ich muss auch fragen,
haben Sie als Erfahrungen mit Träugen gemacht
oder
nehmen Sie es so seit weglieds?
Nee, mit so einem Kram habe ich mich nie befasst, nein.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie schon
mit Ihrer Frau getrennt
sind und geschieden
haben Sie auch Kinder
und sind Sie gesund?
Wir haben eine Tochter,
die ist aber schon
erwachsen und
sie lebt nicht bei mir und sie ist
auch alleine unterwegs.
Gesund, ja, ich denke, die ist gesund, ja.
Okay, okay, Gott sei Dank.
Und gibt es auch
in Ihrer
Familien,
Nähenfamilien wie Mutter
oder Vater
wichtige oder chronische Erkrankungen
und denen ich wissen sollte?
Also meine Mutter ist,
also dafür, dass sie schon so alt ist,
ist sie eigentlich ziemlich fit und gesund, aber
Vater der ist mit
Paar 70, ist er mit
an Darmkrebs gestorben.
Es tut mir leid, aber man
ist ja
Vatergenau gestorben.
78 oder 79, also es ist auch
alt geworden eigentlich.
Okay.
Und haben Sie keine Geschwister?
Nee, ich war alleine.
Okay, Herr Wagner
und ich würde gerne auch wissen, ob
Sie auf etwas allergisch reagiert.
Oh.
Oder Unfaire Träglichkeit,
was Sie bei Ihnen verkannt.
Ich bin so unkomplizierter Mensch,
ich habe nie irgendwas gehabt,
also ich wüsste nicht,
dass ich irgendwas nicht vertragen kann
oder...
Nein, also ich meine nix,
dass ich allergisch bin,
ich wüsste nicht.
Okay, super.
Und sind Sie seit Ihrer Kindheit
vollständig geimpft?
Oder bekommen Sie regelmäßig
Impfungen von Ihrem Haushalt?
Nein, ich gehe da nicht so gerne hin,
wissen Sie, der nervt mich immer
mit meinen Zigaretten und dem Alkohol
und gehe ich dem
so ein bisschen aus dem Weg.
Und ich habe ja auch nix,
also ich habe es außer jetzt,
aber sonst habe ich ja nie was.
Kein Problem, wenn ich mit
Ihrem Hausarzt in Färbinux
sitzen.
Und Herr Wagner, reisen Sie oft
hier seit dem Ausland?
Kann ich mir gar nicht leisten,
wenn mein arbeitslos ist, hat man
nicht so viel Geld, das man
verhaisen kann.
Okay.
Okay Herr Wagner,
tatsächlich habe ich dir
zuerst alle wichtige
Frage für mich gestellt,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
oder haben Sie frei genannt nicht?
Ja, ich will natürlich wissen,
dass es ist und dass man dagegen
auch wissen muss, wie ich die
Schmerzen wieder los werde.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe tatsächlich
Ihr Angst.
Selbstverständlich muss ich
zuerst die körperlich untersuchen
und einige Laboralte kontrollieren.
Danach kann ich Ihnen die
Abschließende Diagnose
mitteilen.
Aber machen Sie sich bitte
keine Sorgen, Sie sind in guter
Hände.
Ja, das will ich mal hoffen.
Mhm.
Dann warten Sie bitte kurz, ich warte Sie
mal, ich werde mich verscheid geben.
Okay, gut.
Okay, ich...
Also tatsächlich
konnte ich auch eine Frage
über Ihre Aktuellenbeschwerden stellen.
Möchte
irgendjemand von den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen noch eine
zusätzliche Frage stellen.
Gibt es irgendwas, was
offen geblieben ist?
Ja, gerne.
Ähm...
Die Schmerzen sind auf einer
Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Ja...
Die sind schon ziemlich stark, die
Schmerzen. Er gibt an so 7 bis 8 von 10.
7 von 8.
Okay, und noch eine Frage.
Wenn haben Sie zum nächsten Mal
etwas gegessen?
Hm...
Ja, heute Nachmittag.
Heute Nachmittag.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, kann ich auch noch
andere Frage stellen.
Und
sind Ihre Schmerzen
plötzlich angefangen oder langsam
aufgetreten?
Ja, ich würde sagen, das hat
langsam angefangen.
Am Anfang denkt man ja immer,
ja, es zweckt mal und so und
dann sagt man, ja, wird schon wieder
aufgetreten. Es ist aber nicht
weggegangen, sondern es ist immer
bei mir geblieben und immer schlimmer
geworden.
Okay, und nehmen Sie regelmäßig
Schmerzmittel und mal geht die
Kumpel. Nein, ich nehme nie
Schmerzmittel, dann tricke ich lieber
ein Bier und schnappe es, als ich
Schmerzmittel nehme.
Okay, und hatten Sie
schwarze Stuhl oder
habe Sie im Stuhl Farbfeyer in
der Rückwärmung bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ja, gerne.
Haben Sie
gehandliche Hautfarbeveränderung
bemerkt?
Ich gucke nicht so genau ins
Spiegel, aber es mir nicht
aufgefallen.
Eine Frage?
Ja, gerne.
Ich bin mir nie sicher, ob
diese Frage gestellt hat,
aber leiden Sie unter
an chronischen Erkrankungen
zum Beispiel.
Ich war immer gesund.
Ich habe noch nie, ich habe
keine Krankheit gehabt und
habe immer gedacht, mir
passiert nichts, ich bin
kreigesund.
Wieso suchen Sie regelmäßig
Ihr Hausarzt? Nein, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht, der ärgert mich immer.
Wann war Ihr letzte Besuch?
Schon lange her.
Ich gehe da ungern hin,
der sagt immer, ich soll
noch ein bisschen mehr davon und
deswegen gehe ich da nicht hin.
Danke.
Diese Angeschheit, wenn Sie
soweit sind, ne?
Ja, es dauert ein bisschen,
danke erstens.
Ja, alles gut.
Ich kann tatsächlich anfangen,
die einige Informationen
und kann ich
während Vorstellung
gut sagen.
Okay, Frau Oberarzt,
ich habe jetzt noch einen neuen
Patienten vorgestellt.
Ja, wie haben Sie denn
gesehen? Erzählen Sie.
Herr Thomas Wagner,
ein 60-jähriger
Patient,
stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit
drei Monaten bestehender
langsam aufgetreten,
der proglädiente und persistieren
der Oberbauchschmerzen vor
und begleitet von
uns, teilte uns mit,
dass er
unter hellfarbiges
Jahre nausher
und vermehrte
nachtliche Hypohydrosis hat
und außerhalb berichtete
der Patient,
dass sie,
außerhalb berichtete
der Patient über
eine Gewichtabnahme
von 8 kg
innerhalb von einem Monaten
und
dem Patienten
verschlimmern sich
ihre Beschwerden nach dem
fertiges Essen
und
Blut
im Stuhl
wurden
verneint
und die vegetative Anamnese
ist unaufwählig
bis
auf oben genannten
die vegetative Anamnese
fällt auf
aber so nicht unaufwählig
ist unaufwählig
bis auf
das ist ja nicht unaufwählig
aufwählig
ne vegetative Anamnese
fällt auf
oder bis auf
Fällt auf, es fällt auf.
Fällt auf in Somni und in Appätenz.
In der Patientin leidet so seit keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Er hat keine chronischen Erkrankungen, ja?
Aber der Patient wurde einmal in der Vergangenheit, ungefähr vor 25 Jahren,
nach einem Autounfall wegen einer Fraktur, ich habe tatsächlich nicht gefragt, operiert.
Er hat die mit Platten Ostern-Santäse behandelt.
Der Patient raucht ungefähr 30 Jahre.
In den letzten 10 Jahren raucht der Patient täglich ein Schachtensirur.
In der Vergangenheit hat er eine halbe Schachtenskarette geraucht.
Und der Patient trinkt regelmäßig ein Fleisch Bier und Drogenkursen, ungefähr.
Bei der Familienanamnese findet sich bei der Mutter des Patienten keine bekannten Krankheiten,
aber bei der Vater des Patienten ist im Alter von 79 Jahren an der Kolonkarsen umgestorben.
Bei der Sozialanamnese gibt es ruhig eine Information, der Patient ist geschieden, lebt so seit allein,
er ist arbeitslos und er hat eine gesunde Tochter.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Die Symptome, die Patienten beschrieben haben, drücken tatsächlich auf einige Krankheiten.
Aber ich gehe von einer Ulkustventruch-Külle aus und es kann auch Ulkustiodeine sein
oder Magenkarsenung sein, weil es einige Beschwerden sprechen dafür.
Wo sind denn die Schmerzen? Wie hat er die Schmerzen denn beschrieben? Denken Sie da nochmal dran bitte.
Es kann auch ein Pankreatitis oder Pankreaskarsenung sein.
Ein Pankreaskarsenung und Pankreatitis soll man auch in Betracht sehen,
weil die Schmerzen des Patienten strahlen in Rücken und linken Seite nicht, oder? Nur Rücken aus.
Und gibt es auch Gewichtverlust und nach dem Fettiges Essen gibt es auch Verschlimmelung.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Selbstverständlich würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Wo achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich bei der Inspektion schon Haltung sehen.
Aber bei der Inspektion und Palkration sowie Palkation sind bei der Bauch-Unsuchung richtig.
Würd ich zuerst den Bauch abhören, die Geräusche?
Daran Geräusche?
Ja, Geräusche würde ich hören oder färmen.
Danach würde ich feststellen, dass die Abwehrspunung oder Druckschmerzen am bestimmten Bereich feststellen.
Und es kann auch... jetzt gibt es ein Rebound-Zeichen, würde ich suchen.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Rebound-Zeichen.
Rebound-Abbwehrspunung und Druckschmerzen.
Worauf wurde eben gerade gefragt nach Änderung im Hautkolorit?
Hautkolorit?
Farbe.
Farbveröhnterung.
Aber gelb ist, wurde noch nicht nachgefragt.
In diesem Fall soll man auch ein Kolesivstitis oder Koleidokolythiasis im Betracht sehen.
Oder ein Stein in diesem Jahr weg auszulissen.
Ja, also Sie gucken eben unter anderem auch nach der Hautfarbe.
Ach so, ja, richtig.
Ja, gut.
Was machen Sie dann sonst noch mit den Patienten?
Dann würde ich dem Patienten Blut abnehmen und einige Laborgeister kontrollieren.
Welche denn zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel großes Blutbild oder Infektionsparameter wie BSC, CRP oder die Leberfunktionen und Nierenfunktionen.
In diesem Fall sollen wir auch ALP und GPD kontrollieren.
Also lieber Nierenwerte würde ich auch Harnstoff und Kreatin fallen.
Ja, also unter dem Aspekt, dass ja Rückenschmerzen angibt, dass man das ausschließt, dass irgendwas mit den Nieren ist.
Als Laborwerte.
Ja, okay.
Und Pankreas-Enzyme, meine Sie, ja.
Ne, Sie haben ja gerade gesagt Nierenwerte.
Ach so, Nierenwerte, die Steine ausschließen oder?
Ja, okay, gut.
Und ja, was lassen Sie noch labortechnisch untersuchen?
Als Bildgeber oder apärative Maßnahmen, meine ich.
Labortechnisch.
Absolut, Labor.
Im Blut.
Oder an Endoscopy, meine Sie, ein Biopsychiatrist.
Nein, ich meine noch, von anders.
Und der Urter seit nicht.
Ich weiß nicht tatsächlich.
Er hat Durchfall angegeben.
Ach so, ja, Stuhlprobe.
Stuhldiagnostik, ja, okay.
Möglicherweise auch jetzt in Bezug auf Nierenprobleme, Urindiagnostik könnte man auch noch machen.
Gut, ja.
Und ja, was würden Sie apparativ machen mit den Patienten?
Zunächst würde ich eine Ultraschalluntersuchung durchführen.
Bestimmt gegebenenfalls würde ich auch eine Marke oder Kontrastmittel,
Kompetentomographie mit Kontrastmittel veranlassen.
Aber...
Wovon?
Damit können wir die Öl im Pankreas oder Galenbilasen oder Galensteine feststellen.
Okay.
Aber Goldstandard würde ich sagen ein Endoscopy.
Okay, ja, auf alle Fälle, ne?
Genau.
Gut, ja.
Dann nehmen Sie den Patienten auf, der hat ja doch ziemlich stark geschmerzen, oder?
Was meine Sie, der Patient soll jetzt...
Nehmen Sie ihn stationär auf.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Aber zuerst würde ich solche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Nach den Ergebnissen der Untersuchung kann ich die Entscheidung treffen.
Aber es sieht tatsächlich so aus, der Patient soll stationär behandelt werden.
Okay, gut.
Ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was rauskommt bei Ihren Untersuchungen
und dann sprechen wir nachher noch über die Ergebnisse und was unsere finale Diagnose ist.
Ja, was meinen Sie?
Was ist es tatsächlich?
Es kann auch ein chronischer Pankreatitis oder Pankreaskahtionom sein.
Ja, also tatsächlich in diesem Fall, es ist die chronische Pankreatitis.
Und eigentlich hat er einen...
Hat er Ihnen einen schönen Hinweis gegeben.
Das ist so der Klassiker und das haben Sie leider...
Haben Sie es nicht erwähnt im Oberarztgespräch.
Ich habe gesagt, die Schmerzen sind im Oberbauch und sie strahlen in den Rücken
und sie gehen so rundherum.
So, das ist diese berühmte Geschichte mit den gürtelförmigen Bauchschmerzen.
Das ist so der Stichwort.
Gut, und damit landen Sie irgendwie ziemlich fix bei der Pankreatitis.
Also in diesem Fall chronische Pankreatitis, weil es seit Monaten ist.
Gut, das war die Geschichte.
Und ja, was würde man dann tatsächlich mit den Patienten machen, wenn man den Stadionä aufgenommen hat?
Ich kann ein großer Erklärung machen.
Bitte?
Ja?
Wieso?
Ich würde erst zwei Benötzelsugang erlegen oder gegebenenfalls Sauerstoff über Nasensonde geben
oder Flüssigkeits verabreichen.
Je nach der Diagnose würde ich den Patienten mittels ERCP behandeln.
ERCP ist auch Diagnostische Massnahme und Therapeutische Massnahme.
Das ist auch sowohl.
Ja, und ja, Sie haben es schon gesagt, er kriegt zwei Zugänge.
Was würde man ihm empfehlen, was Ernährung angeht?
Die Ernährung bei der stationäre Aufnahme soll Patienten tatsächlich nichts essen, Ernährung ist gar nicht.
Aber nach der Behandlung sollte der Patient Protein und Fettik, wie man nicht sagen, gar nicht.
Ach so, okay, also eine relativ leichte Kost und viele kleine Mahlzeiten.
Ja.
Keine großen, üppigen Mahlzeiten, sondern mehrere kleine Mahlzeiten.
Und was natürlich auch als Allgemeine Massnahme.
Ja, Sie haben ihn angesprochen?
Rauchen Entwürcungen und auch Alkoholentwürcungen.
Ja, also der brauchen Nikotinkarrenz und Alkoholkarrenz, ja, genau.
Gut, ja, mir ist wieder aufgefallen.
Mit dem Patienten reden Sie sehr nett und sprechen mit Ihnen sehr schön und gucken Ihnen an.
Und mit der Oberärztin reden Sie überhaupt nicht.
Da legen Sie alles ab, was Sie aufgeschrieben haben.
Sie sind nämlich sehr viel mehr an.
Sprechen Sie mit Ihrem Gegenüber, indem Sie ihn angucken.
Ja, so wirklich. Das ist so viel netter.
Ja, Sie haben eigentlich schön Anamnese gemacht und das war ja auch eine schnelle Geschichte.
Der Patient hatte ja eigentlich nicht viel und er hatte ziemlich eindeutige Symptome.
Und ja, man konnte tatsächlich noch diese Ulgrusgeschichten,
diese Bauchschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Das kann natürlich immer alles sein.
Das ist schon richtig.
Und ja, was kann ich dazu sagen?
Eine winzige Sache.
Eine winzige Sache ist mir aufgefallen in Ihrem Arztgespräch.
Der Patient hat nicht gesagt, dass er nur eine Flasche Bier am Abend trinkt.
Er trinkt deutlich mehr.
Sie haben auch nicht so konkret danach gefragt.
Aber er hat schon gesagt, dass er schon ein paar Bier braucht am Abend.
Und der Tag ist ja auch lang, hat er gesagt, also ja, da muss man dann schon,
damit rechnet er es ein bisschen mehr als ein Bier trinkt.
Und ja, das macht er auch.
Und was Sie nicht gefragt haben, seit wann er arbeitslos ist.
Und was er vorher beruflich gemacht hat.
Das ist vielleicht auch manchmal interessant,
weil das einmal natürlich auf diesem psychischen Stress Arbeitslosigkeit.
Sie kennen diese Stigmatisierung, die Leute haben, die keinen Job haben.
Da wird dann mit dem Finger gezeigt, die sind ja alle faul
und wollen nur Stütze abkassieren.
Also ich glaube, der soziale Druck ist da schon ziemlich groß.
Der Mann ist geschieden.
Ja, also und so alt ist er ja nur noch nicht mit 60.
Der hat also irgendwie schon psychosozialen Stress sicherlich.
Und ich denke, das sind so Sachen, die dann auch zusammenkommen,
sollte man sicherlich im Bericht mit erwähnen.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, hätte ich das schon gerne gemacht.
Ich hätte das schon gerne gehört, dass Sie der Oberärztin sagen,
ja, der Patient beschreibt, gürtelfärmige Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ansonsten haben Sie den eigentlich, finde ich,
diese Formulierung haben Sie sehr, sehr schön gemacht.
Dass Sie gestellt, sich vorwägen.
Und dann kam eigentlich komplett alles sehr kompakt.
Haben Sie schön gemacht.
Dankeschön.
Wo Sie den Patienten genervt haben, haben Sie wahrscheinlich gemerkt.
Das ist das Stichwort mit der Rauchentwöhnung.
Wenn ich wahnsinnige Bauchschmerzen habe und wegen Durchfallen und Bauchwee zum Arzt komme,
dann will ich nicht hören, dass der mir was zu meinem Rauchgewohnheiten sagt.
Deswegen geht der Typ schon nicht zu seinem Hausarzt hin,
weil der ihn nervt.
Er sagt, eben trinken Sie mal ein bisschen weniger
und rauchen Sie mal ein bisschen weniger.
Deswegen geht er dem schon aus dem Weg.
Dann kommt das wahrscheinlich nicht so gut,
wenn Sie ihm sagen, ja, wir sollten mal darüber sprechen,
ob Sie was gegen Ihren Rauch in Nikotinkonsum tun.
Ich denke immer, da muss die Situation schon ein bisschen anders sein.
Klar ist das vielleicht in dem Augenblick,
wo Sie jemanden mit Gefäßverschlüssen in den Beinen haben,
der also gelbe Finger hat und wie so ein Aschernbecher riecht,
den muss man vielleicht sagen,
mit Ihren Beinen, das wird nicht besser, wenn Sie weiter so rauchen.
Aber ich glaube, da muss man tatsächlich so ein bisschen die Situation abwarten
und ein Päckchen, das ist ja für unsere Verhältnisse eigentlich noch moderater Nikotinkonsum.
Was meinen Sie, was Leute in Deutschland rauchen und saufen?
Das ist unglaublich.
Dann haben wir unsere Fallbeispiele, sind wirklich harmlos, alle.
Und ja, in der Realität werden Sie ganz anderen Konsum begegnen.
Was ich immer auffällig finde an unseren Fällen,
wie wenig Drogenkonsum es gibt,
in der Tat scheint es ja ein riesen Thema zu sein in unserer Gesellschaft.
Aber da wird man auch sicherlich auf direkte Anfrage nur seltenreherliche Antworten bekommen,
genauso wie Sie kaum ehrliche Antworten bekommen, wenn Sie nach Alkohol fragen.
Sie will Ihnen keiner sagen, dass er schon zum zweiten Frühstück den Koenjak in der Kaffeetasse hat.
Das werden die Leute Ihnen nicht erzählen, aber es gibt es.
Und das ist nicht so selten, das ist leider so.
Gut, ansonsten haben Sie sich also wackergeschlagen.
Ich denke mal, Sie können Ihre Prüfung am 21. können Sie sehr gelassen entgegensehen.
Sie können gut mit der Sprache umgehen.
Wie gesagt, gucken Sie den Prüfer mal an, gucken Sie nicht nur auf Ihre Zettel.
Das ist schon deutlich netter.
Hab ich Ihnen glaube ich schon mal gesagt, ne?
Ja, ich denke.
Ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen das schon mal gesagt.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich würde sagen, dann können wir uns für heute Abend verabschieden.
Wir sehen uns wieder gerne, wenn Sie mögen, am Donnerstag.
Dr. Pugel, wie ist die Stimmung?
Es gibt schon einen Termin, ich denke.
Er hat einen Termin.
Okay, dann ist er vielleicht gar nicht da.
Nein, nein, am Donnerstag hat jemand schon einen Termin für Sie.
Ach so, okay, ja, wunderbar, umso besser.
Also ich bin Donnerstag da und dann schauen wir, was wir dann zusammen machen.
Für heute wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend.
Alle, die ich vorhin noch nicht entsprechend angesprochen habe,
weil ich das nur mit den ersten besprochen habe,
Ihnen allen wünsche ich einen guten Start ins neue Jahr.
Fangen Sie es gut an, bringen Sie eine Menge Optimismus mit
und so viel engagement, dass Sie hier gut klarkommen.
Also tschüss zusammen.
Vielen Dank.
Einen schönen Abend für heute und bis übermorgen.
Ciao, ciao.
Dankeschön, schönen Abend.